on soir franck 20 merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes donc opposés à la loi
bioéthique et vous avez manifesté ce
week end à meaux qu'est ce qui suscite
le plus votre opposition aujourd'hui
alors déjà on pense que cette loi passe
en catimini un moment où on pense que
gouvernement autre chose à faire que
passer cette loi on est un petit peu
surpris a pas vraiment de deux débats
et puis je ce qui nous agace le plus
c'est comment l'enfant est considérée
voilà on parle du on parle du droit et
des barres en avoir un enfant mais on
pense jamais à à ce que l'enfant lui et
c'est ce que je pense c'est le mieux
pour lui d'avoir un père et une mère
voilà et dans le cadre d'une baie
mahault où une gpa et ben c'est pas le
cas et donc je pense qu'on franchit une
ligne rouge et je pense que c'est bon on
déconstruit quelque part quelque chose
et ça c'est dangereux
vous parlez du contexte quelle est donc
cette loi et discuter à nouveau sénat ça
va jouer ça va peser pour vous d'une
certaine manière ça va passer inaperçu
beaucoup sur les sénateurs je sais qu
enseignement par exemple ils sont très
actifs ils ont modifié ce qui avait été
rédigé par l'assemblée nationale
non je crois je pense qu'on est dans un
système de bicaméralisme ou dans lequel
le sénat a son mot à dire
et le gouvernement ne doit pas faire
attraction de ce que lille sénat je
pense notamment à tous qui est
marchandisation du corps humain
on le voit sur les images là à côté lors
de la manifestation de dimanche dernier
on voit ces bébés avec des dollars et
des codes-barres voilà aujourd'hui on
propose des des banques de sperme ou
vous pouvez déjà acheter des enfants du
sperme qui va vous donner un enfant avec
des yeux bleus ou des enfants plus
intelligents que d'autres je pense que
ça c'est dangereux on peut aussi
aujourd'hui via internet
reporté son enfant parce que la femme
n'a pas envie de le porter par par une
femme aux philippines à qui on leur a
versé 10 mille euros toutes ces choses
là c'est une dérive inquiétante je pense
que notre société
je pense qu on déconstruit vraiment je
demande d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui a
vraiment derrière tout ça c'est à dire
on sait pas vraiment les minorités qui
sont cachés derrière derrière ces lois
pourquoi emmanuel macron a besoin de
faire passer cette loi là en ce moment
est-ce qu'il veut se rapporte à se
rattacher les électeurs dans la main
pour les élections à venir on sait pas
trop on sait pas trop alors la position
ouverture de des pma aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes seules
mais pas de prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale pour ces nouveaux
bénéficiaires est ce que ça serait tout
de même acceptable pour vous pas tout à
fait la question qu'ont ceux dont on a
peur c'est que derrière le mariage pour
tous on avait dit aura pas de pma il n'y
aura pas que j'ai fait un bon
aujourd'hui on parle de la pma à l'avant
ce projet de loi et on dira pas que gpa
la gp11 c'est la gestation pour autrui
et donc ces pays une femme ou demain
peut-être un utérus artificiel pour
porter des enfants
on pense que voilà pour le bien de
l'enfant
on parle d'écologie aussi beaucoup en ce
moment je pense que l'écologie c'est pas
uniquement
c'est une idée l'écologie mais n'a pas
jusqu'à l'homme et mais voilà il faut
qu'elle soit intégrale cette écologie et
pas uniquement une écologie nature l
avance et on a un nombre d'élus devrait
s'opposer également aux modes de
filiation retenu par les députés pour
les enfants des couples de femmes 1
conçu par pma sa fragiliserait le code
civil selon
la république n 1 co rapporteur de la
commission spéciale c'est également
votre avis oui bien sûr c'était amusant
parce que les slogans
alors je vais pas vous les chanter à la
télé mais les slogans c'était je sais
pas si vous m'entendez encore voilà donc
les stockant c'était un père une mère
c'est élémentaire ou alors l'autre au
slogan c etais s'etait je sais plus et
attendez je retrouve sur des balles p
papa papa tu es fantastique maman maman
maman tu es unique voilà toujours ce
cette recherche pour le pour l'enfant le
bien de l'enfant d'avoir un papa et une
maman tout simplement elle c'est pas
quelque chose de c'est pas des c'est pas
violent quoi c'est pas compliqué c'est
quelque chose d'assez dire de celle
écolo est assez simple merci en tout cas
franck e bouvin voulons vous entendez
mais vous avez été un petit peu basculer
à l'envers mais vous étiez toujours avec
moi basculer à l'envers au niveau de
l'image bien évidemment merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur rtl france